[Música]
salud en directo américa de france 24
conmigo en el estudio más romeros a la
mar bienvenida a feliz viernes vamos a
comenzar entonces con la famosa por esos
tiempos vino la del mono y la nueva
información que tenemos sobre su
genética así es raúl muy buenos días
estamos hablando de un estudio publicado
en la revista en el ser hoy mismo esta
mañana desarrollado por universidades
portuguesas que ha secuenciado pues
varios virus del brote actual el que se
está extendiendo para llegar a una serie
de conclusiones vamos a escuchar lo que
opinaba fernando gonzález que es un
genetista que estaba explicando pues en
science media center 1 portal de
noticias de español que pensaba de este
estudio
el resultado más destacable es demostrar
que el brote detectado en varios países
casi simultáneamente tiene un origen
único y además que en ese origen está
implicado un virus que ha experimentado
un número importante de cambio respecto
a los virus más próximos de la misma
especie identificados hasta el momento
estos cambios genéticos parecen estar
vinculados a adaptaciones al nuevo
huésped es decir que inicialmente se
pensaba que podía haber surgido de dos
brotes distintos pero ahora se refuerza
esa teoría de solo un brote y también de
que estamos ante unas mutaciones que
suceden más rápido de lo que previamente
también se pensaba que había esperar de
hecho el mismo estudio cita una
evolución acelerada en curso de este
virus recordemos además que el virus de
la viruela del mono suele saltar de
animales a humanos y ahí sólo encuentra
unas cuatro personas de cadena de
transmisión ahora claramente estamos en
una situación diferente la organización
mundial de la salud ya cifra en 3200 los
casos que hay en decenas de países de
hecho también nos despertamos con la
noticia de que en colombia se han
detectado los tres primeros y pues
además todavía estamos a la espera de
que el grupo de emergencias de la ume se
decida si realmente se trata de una de
emergencia de salud pública global o no
merece pues de este nivel de alerta tan
alto vamos a ver qué va a pasar cuando
tenemos esa declaración de la oms aquí
se ve que el virus haya mutado más
rápido ahora pues precisamente este
estudio arroja una teoría que nos puede
servir y es que el virus círculo entre
humanos sin saberse o sin detectarse sin
vigilar se durante bastante tiempo en
nigeria porque nigeria digamos el
ancestro del virus más parecido más
cercano que han encontrado a los que hay
actualmente circulando en el resto del
mundo y pues que después de levantar las
cuarentenas de que el mundo volviera a
recuperar la movilidad se ha contagiado
se ha expandido de forma más rápido
vamos a repasar la genética de este
virus se trata de un virus de adn es
decir que tiene dos hebras de adn como
nosotros y esto codifica 200 proteínas
que en este caso si es mucho menos que
nuestro material genético normalmente
eso hace que los virus sean más estables
que muten menos porque al reproducirse
hay menos errores pero en este caso
vemos que no ha sucedido así porque
bueno porque los humanos tenemos unos
enzimas que se llaman apop beck 3 son lo
que hacen estos encimas es que
introducen unas mutaciones en los virus
e intentan combatir la infección así
para que no se puedan reproducir tengan
errores o dejan dejen de funcionar que
ha pasado que a veces en este proceso de
introducir estas mutaciones se hacen
unas mutaciones que en fin al final son
beneficiosas para el virus eso ha pasado
por ejemplo con el virus del vih que
cambien estas pequeñas informaciones de
material genético se hace eso
básicamente lo que hace es que sea pues
más transmisible y esté más cómodo
digamos del virus dentro de los humanos
esto podría explicar por qué después de
haberse transmitido más tiempo entre
humanos haya habido más posibilidades de
que existan estas mutaciones y ahora
pues sea un virus que está más adaptado
a la transmisión entre personas bueno
mari dejamos a un lado la viruela del
mono vamos a cambiar de tema para hablar
de la polio porque en dónde se
encontraron se encontró el virus de la
polio en aguas residuales íbamos de
emergencia
vírica últimamente básicamente
igualmente es importante recordar que
han dicho que no hay una emergencia o
una crisis un riesgo de infección porque
las tasas de vacunación siguen altas
pero no está de más recordar qué es muy
importante vacunar a todos los hijos e
hijas de contra esta enfermedad contra
la polio además sobre todo porque
durante la pandemia de kobe 19 pues han
descendido normalmente esas tasas de
vacunación y se considera que para
prevenir el brote se necesita
aproximadamente una cobertura del 90 por
ciento de la población importante
también recordar que actualmente sólo a
afganistán y pakistán se consideran
países donde esta enfermedad es endémica
pero que sucede que en otros países pues
haya brotes esporádicos aunque no
estemos hablando de un brote en el caso
del reino unido marc cómo se explica que
desde entonces se encuentra este virus
en las aguas residuales de londres sin
casos todavía conocidos de infección
pues la respuesta está en los tipos de
vacunas que se usan contra la polio para
convertir hay dos tipos de vacunas que
se usan una que está en desarrollo la
primera es la vacuna inyectada esta
vacuna lo que inocula es un virus que
está in activado eso significa que se
usa el virus pero no puede infectar
protege de la parálisis de la enfermedad
pero puede ser que una persona se
contagie del virus y lo deseche luego
otra vacuna es la vacuna oral que es la
que se administra por ejemplo en
afganistán o en pakistán pakistán
que será un virus vivo pero debilitado
da una inmunidad mucho más fuerte pero
puede ser también que el cuerpo después
de que hayan administrado esta vacuna lo
deseche con tus excrementos al cabo de
unos días y hay un riesgo y es que
personas con sistemas inmunes
debilitados pueden albergar este virus
durante más tiempo del que debería ser y
se convierta mucho se convierta en un
virus derivado de la vacuna se llama que
si tenga capacidad de infectar por
último también nombrar que hay una
vacuna que está siendo pues desarrollada
que no usa material genético del virus
para intentar evitar todos estos
problemas hasta año hasta ahora perdón
una vez al año más o menos londres se
encontraba restos de virus que podían
suceder eso por de personas que les
acababan de dar esta vacuna oral y que
posteriormente pues viajaban a londres y
como explicábamos desechaba en este
virus y por eso lo encontraban en las
aguas residuales pero ahora la alarma
real es que este virus es uno de estos
virus que decimos derivados de la vacuna
que si tiene capacidad de infectar que
puede ser que la persona fuera una
persona inmundo comprimido pues con
problemas en su sistema inmune o que lo
hubiera transmitido a otras personas y
que luego
han desechado esto es lo que ocurre por
primera vez desde los años 80 por eso
ahora toca aumentar un poco el nivel de
alarma también la tasa de vacunación y
por eso también recordamos pues la
importancia de la vigilancia
epidemiológica que tienen tan claro
cuándo avisar cuando no cuando es un
problema y cuando no más muchísimas
gracias como siempre por la información
de salud personas a saludar en nuestro
segundo invitado el día